[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition du 78 lactu
du vendredi 28 février comme tous les
jours nous allons faire le point complet
sur votre actualité locale en fin
d'émission en fin de journal je
recevrait Jacques Fournier le le
directeur de la maison de poésie de 50
ans en yeline nous parlerons évidemment
du 16e Printemps des Poètes mais tout
d'abord cette information dont nous vous
parlions ces deux derniers jours dans
nos éditions suite à leur manifestation
devant l'hôtel de ville de trappe pour
réclamer la réhabilitation de leur
structure les représentants du club de
football ont été reçus ce jeudi soir par
le maire guimalandin un entretien jugé
constructif par les footballeurs le
maire aurait visité les installations du
club et aurait ciblé quelques
problématiques notamment sur le stade
Gagarine où le club demande
l'installation d'un terrain synthétique
verdict cel
petit rentour en arrière pour mieux
comprendre cette situation Ferrari SIM
je vous le rappelle des licenciés du
club de football de traap on manifesté
ce mercredi devant la mairie pour crier
leur dépit face à DISY l'indescence de
leurs infrastructures où il n'y aurait
plus d'entraînement depuis un mois et
demi pour certains enfants pour rappel
une situation qui avait conduit à la
démission du président du club mstapha
Larbaoui
explication le club de football de Trapp
et la mairie entame un nouveau match aès
la démission
présidentar entre 150 et 250 enfants
éducateurs et parents ont crié leur
colère sous les fenêtre de l'hôtel de
ville parce son et pour des question
sécurité on peut pas y aller c'est la
sécurité parce jour d'aujourd'hui on
bricole et le jour où on aura des ppins
reprochera dans les RS du club seulement
qu terrains ser fonctionnel de au stade
Robert grav et de à Gilbert chansac don
un réservé exclus
et tout c pour 900 licenci de son cé la
mairie avance que terrains ser disponi
sur la commune dans l'attente d'une
éventuelle signature de convention avec
la ville de La Verrière pour des prês de
terrain le club trapiste semble se
retrouver dans
l'impasseère TR pe plus pratier leotall
de manièrere
aujourd'huiation TR très simple consiste
demander des liux accueill pour les
adér il vient de weekend et des outils
pour travailler malgré leur demande
d'audience la délégation n'a pas été
reçue par le maire guimalandin ou ses
représentants autre conflit autre grève
cette fois-ci à guuille en cours les
salariés d'Aka technologie ont manifesté
ce vendredi matin pour protester contre
la politique de l'entreprise de modifier
le barê de remboursement de frais les
employés perdent en moyenne près de 400
€ par mois une négociation est en cours
depuis le 9 juillet 2013 à noter qu'
technologie a fait état d'un chiffre
d'affaires de 231 million d'euros 4e
trimestre 2013 en repli d'1,6 % mais le
groupe a légèrement dépassé son objectif
de 875 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires annuel affaire à suivre ce
lundi à versaill de jeunes majeurs sans
papier ont rencontré leurs nouveaux
parins et marines depuis plusieurs
années le Réseau éducation sans
frontières des ivelines organise ses
rencontres pour protéger les jeunes
scolarisés qui vivent sous la menace
d'une expulsion yolent tores
à Versailles ce lundi 17 jeunes majeurs
sans papiers ont été parrainés un
événement organisé par le Réseau
éducation sans frontière depuis
plusieurs années l'objectif protéger ces
jeunes en cas d'interpellation et agir
pour leur régularisation c'est en tout
cas le rôle de chaque Parin et Marine
comme Nicole book marine d'un jeune
lycéen en première année de CAP
mécanique il peut nous appeler n'importe
quand il a notre il à notre numéro de
téléphone et on peut aussitôt intervenir
en fonction de la nature du problème
s'il est
arrêté et
cetera on est là pour le soutenir c'est
important pour eux de savoir qu'il y a
des des adultes qui s'engagent à leur
côté lorsqu'ils étaient mineurs la
moitié de ces jeunes étaient pris en
charge par l'aide sociale à l'enfance
mais une fois majeur il n'en bénéficie
plus et se retrouve confronté à des
difficultés chaque jeune a deux parins
un citoyen qui le suit et un élu pour un
rôle plus symbolique ils font le mar
pour pouvoir m'aider pour pouvoir
continuer mes études
une dizaine d'autres majeurs seront
parrainés d'ici quelques
jours vous l'avez peut-être suivi cette
semaine le guide Michelin a décerné ses
étoiles traditionnelles l'occasion de
nous intéresser au label délivré au
restaurateurs et dans lesines il sont
peu nombreux à vrai dire en posséd
exemple avec ce restaurant de Montini le
broteneux qui est le seul de 50 ans à
obtenir et détenir de la belle celui de
maître restaurateur et le titre de
collège culinaire de France Olivier
Maniscalco deè label de qualité pour le
restaurant La Fontaine à Montini en mars
2013 l'établissement avait déjà reçu le
titre de collège culinaire de France
reconnaissance par des professionnels
d'une cuisine de qualité cette fois
début février c'est le label maître
restaurateur qui est inauguré ce dernier
décerné par l'État récompense également
la qualité des produits proposés par
l'établissement le restaurant spécialisé
dans le poisson et autres produits de la
mer est aujourd'hui le seul sur
Saint-Quentin en Yveline à détenir ses
deux sésames une fierté une récompense
mais je regrette quand même qu'on soit
pas un peu plus nombreux c'est un moyen
aussi de lutter contre on va dire la
malbouffe hein il ont pas peur des
mots la cuisine industrielle qu'on voit
un petit peu partout dans les médias il
y a des débats des émissions et cetera
donc là il y a deux labels pour rassurer
le consommateur Maré de ringis marché de
Versailles pisculture bio en Normandie
la traçabilité est un critère important
pour le chef José Morlot et même si les
deux labels apportent une bonne
publicité à l'établissement son patron
regrette d'être seul gage de cette
qualité dans l'agglomération pour lui
avec d'autres restaurateurs labellisé à
Saint-Quentin les clients n'iraient pas
autant voir ailleurs sur la ville
nouvelle par exemple on serait un peu
plus nombreux dans ce cas de figure ça
nous permettrait de fixer la clientèle
sur la ville nouvelle et d'avoir un peu
moins de fuite vers versaill vers Paris
vers la vallée de chevvreuse voilà donc
évidemment je suis fier qu'on soit dans
cette situation mais j'appelle mes
collègues à venir avec nous des
collègues restaurateur souvent mal
informé sur ce type de label pourtant le
titre de Maître Restaurateur peut
permettre un crédit d'impôt allant
jusqu'à 15000 € dans les Yvelines seul
27 établissements sur 1000 restaurants
l'ont
obtenu je vous en parlais en titre de ce
journal le 3 mars prochain sera donné le
départ du 16e Printemps des Poètes à la
Maison de la poésie de 50 ans en Yveline
un événement évidemment attendu hein par
tous les passionnés d'art et pour en
parler évidemment le directeur de la
Maison de la Poésie Jacques four est
présent sur ce plateau bonjour à vous
bonjour Merci de de nous rejoindre tout
d'abord cette année le thème c'est la
poésie au cœur des arts dites-nous-en un
petit peu plus alors ça c'est c'est un
thème national c'est tous les ans le
Printemps des Poètes donc la
l'association propose un thème on suit o
on suit pas nous c'est ce qu'on fait
toute l'année depuis 12 ans c'est-à-dire
qu'on fait en sorte que la poésie soit
associée à d'autres formes de création
la plupart du temps musique danse
théâtre exposition sculpture peinture et
cetera donc pour nous c'est c'est
vraiment euh un thème fédérateur
c'est-à-dire ça permet à la fois de de
toucher les gens qui viennent pour
entendre des poèmes des textes dits par
des poédiens des comédiens ou des poètes
et des d'autres personnes qui viennent
plus pour la partie non poétique
c'est-à-dire toute la partie
complémentaire supplémentaire qui qui
vient qui s'associe donc là on a on a on
va proposer une grande soirée autour de
danse et poésie il s'appelle danser les
mots avec trois courts spectacles de une
demi-heure 45 5 minutes chacun dans la
même soirée donc on aura à la fois des
gens passionnés par la danse et des gens
passionnés par la poésie donc ça permet
cette combinaison là ce printon des
poète c'est l'occasion pour un petit peu
les les amateurs et puis aussi les non
initiés de de découvrir toutes les
formes de création c'est un peu ça aussi
bah on essaie oui c dire qu'on essaie de
de de
proposer d' d'ouvrir le champ le plus
large possible en tout en restant dans
une qualité d'écriture on est on a une
une grande exigence à ce niveau-là mais
le le le champ est très ouvert
c'est-à-dire entre un Charles benkin qui
qui qui va travailler venir avec le
danseur Dominique ggou qui est un poète
de la performance de de de l'oralité
dans la puissance et une Jacqueline
persini panorias qui viendra animer un
atelier d'écriture à la médiathèque
Jacques Brell et dont les textes seront
mis en voie par le théâtre de la cavale
où on est dans une écriture qui est plus
de l'intime euh plus proche de l'image
que les ans ont peut-être de la poésie
voilà on essaie de de de de de jouer sur
ce spectre là auprès auprès du public
pour lui montrer que la poésie ben elle
est elle est faite pour tous euh et elle
elle est elle est accessible à tous le
message de ce printemps des poètes je
sais que c'est aussi un de vos combats
la poésie ce n'est pas seulement des
rimes c'est présent dans toutes les
expressions artistiques au final c'est
ça complètement mais même dans
l'écriture je veux dire la la rime est
quelque chose qui a quand même été on va
dire brocardé largement depuis 150 ans
n'oublions pas que rimau est quand même
a quand même écrit ses grands textes en
1870 71 ça fait quand même une paille
donc depuis la rime certes c'est c'est
c'est elle elle a sa place
mais on travaille aussi sur les on
travaille surtout beaucoup pour les sur
les poètes d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
ceux qui utilisent le vocabulaire
d'aujourd'hui la langue d'aujourd'hui on
parle pas en alexandrin on parle pas en
octosyllabe ils utilisent l'alexandrin
ils utilisent l'octosyllabe on ne parle
pas en riman on n'est pas dans le
théâtre de de racine de Corneille on est
dans une écriture complètement ancrée
dans le présent donc on montre cette
écriture là qui parle de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on va aborder des thèmes
très différents on va avoir une soirée à
Paris par exemple avec la poète
israélienne adasata
et et un poète syrien on va
voir on va voir une soirée autour de
Valérie rousau qui est une des grandes
de la poésie contemporaine qui travaille
beaucoup avec la langue française
beaucoup dans l'humour aussi mais dans
dans dans le quotidien on a publié en
carte postale un texte d'elle qui parle
de la de la misère c'est-à-dire de de de
la de l' mendicité c'est vraiment
d'aujourd'hui c'est c'est on peut pas
plus avec une langue d'aujourd'hui et
pour rester dans le présent un petit peu
plus si j'ose dire vous allez investir
des lieux peu commun au final pour
donner donner envie et surtout lire des
poèmes oui peu commun et surtout voilà
on a on crée des partenariats ça c'est
c'est plus traditionnel avec la ferme de
bbas pour une grande journée le 22 mars
il y aura 5in spectacles dans la même
journée on terminera avec Angélique
yonatos il c'est pas rien on travaille
avec la Merise avec la scène nationale
aussi et on va investir oui le le le 8
mars c'est la Journée du poème à l'autre
c'est on a gardé cette appellation là
c'est le la place au poème aussi c'estàd
qu'on va investir une nouvelle fois le
marché des Merisiers de de 10h à 13h à
peu près avec trois compagnies amateur
voilà à trappe le marché le le plus
fréquenté de de 5tin en Eveline et on va
lâcher comme ça une quinzaine de
comédiens euh des compagnies what's to
do passage à l'acte et compte en bande
et ils ont des textes on leur a donné un
corpus de textte des poètes qu'on invite
sur le festival et ils vont dire ces
textes aux gens et en même temps on va
leur distribuer on va distribuer à ces
gens des cartes postales sur lesquelles
on a fait imprimer des poèmes de nos
invités voilà on essaie de faire en
sorte que les gens gardent une trace de
tout ça la trace c'est important donc
nous on est là pour donner des traces
aux gens vous avez déjà donné quelques
indice mais il y aura des moments forts
j'imagine pendant ce mois de mars là ce
printemp des poètes oui il y aura la
soirée hommage à Valérie rousau le le
hommage on va dire une carte blanche à
Valérie rousau avec une ses invités et
un spectacle construit à partir de ses
propres textes il y aura le la création
d'un d'un moi j'attends ça avec beaucoup
d'impatience la création de Pablo
Picasso poèmes et propos par Bernard
Ascal c'est c'est un un CD livre CD
qu'on a soutenu avec la Maison de la
poésie dont on a soutenu la publication
qui a reçu un coup de cœur de l'Académie
charlescro l'an dernier et il a il il le
montera sur scène avec des musiciens ça
ça sera le le le 27 le 27 mars à la
Maison de la Poésie voilà c'est c'est ça
fait partie des temps des temps forts il
y en aura plein il y a l'exposition
actuellement qui a commencé en février
et qui se prolongera jusqu'au 29 mars
l'exposition des la collection de de
Louis et Annique douset à la Maison de
la Poésie voilà on a comme ça des des
des temps forts euh il suffit d'aller
voir le programme sur le site internet
c'est plus pratique si les
téléspectateurs justement veulent voir
un petit peu tout le détail de ce
programme inter de ce programme
rendez-vous sur votre site internet
évidemment qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci beaucoup et puis une
dernière petite information n'hésitez
pas à aller sur le kiosk le site
internet kiosk pour aller acheter vos
billets pour venir voir les spectacles à
la maison et avec la Maison de la Poésie
merci merci Jacques Fournier donc
Printemps des Poètes ce 16e Printemps
des Poètes débute donc je vous le
rappelle le 3 mars prochain ce lundi
merci beaucoup Jacques four merci c'est
la fin de ce 78 lactu merci encore une
fois de l'avoir suivi je vous retrouve
dans le 78 weekend pour toutes vos idées
de sortie d'ici là excellente soirée sur
[Musique]
TVfil